randy aloses merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors en pleine
mobilisation contre le racisme aux états
unis le ministre de la défense s'est dit
ouvert à l'idée de rebaptiser certaines
bases
comment interprétez vous ce nouveau
contre-pied finalement une prise de
position du président entre up
pour rappel le secrétaire à la défense
avait déjà rejeté l'idée de déployer
l'armée contre les manifestants il
s'agit au mourre une démarche purement
politique de la part des démocrates pour
essayer dé politiser cette situation en
amérique
face aux émeutes vous devez savoir que
dans notre histoire il ya un héritage
très forts concrets à avant la guerre
civile dans l'esclavagé tombe
si on suit la logique émana pelosi elle
souhaiterait par la suite aujourd'hui
c'est les noms des bases militaires
demain ils voudront effacer george
washington times jeffrey shen mist adams
de notre histoire parce qu'eux aussi
étaient propriétaires d'esclaves
à l'époque ils veulent changer
totalement la vision et l'héritage de
notre pays pour faire de la politique et
changer ça radicalement pas par pas ils
veulent changer des choses c'est comme
en france
qu'est-ce qu'on vous devrez faire face à
cette situation avec napoléon qui a
réinstauré l'esclavagé en 1802 est-ce
qu'on va y passer napoléon des toute
l'histoire de la france impossible donc
c'est le même problème on peut pas faire
ça bien conduit à un contexte et s'était
fait dans l'esprit de la conciliation
suite india meurtrière avec les sudistes
et c'est dans cet esprit de conciliation
qui les noms étaient gardés pour essayer
d'avoir un esprit de conciliation est
passé à autre chose
c'est le passé on tourne la page à ces
moments difficiles dans notre histoire
c'est la même chose qu'est ce qu'on
dirait pas encore président roosevelt
que tout le monde dit elle prend
d'hommes il a interne et toutes les
japonais américains des citoyens
américains étaient
on est dans des camps 3 enfin dans la
deuxième guerre mondiale
donc on va retirer aussi son nom des
livres de l'histoire
il s'est aligné avec les
ségrégationnistes
à cette époque aussi monsieur roosevelt
dont il faut tout changer toute notre
histoire
donc aujourd'hui c'est une démarche très
très dangereuses on au palais sur ce
chemin il ya des explications
il y a des lives et à l'école pour
expliquer lé contexte on peut même
mettre des plats au niveau de ses
statuts pour expliquer de quoi il s'agit
dans quel contexte historique ça s'est
passé et comment ça a évolué et
aujourd'hui les choses le plus important
c'est l'égalité entre toutes les ethnies
c'est ça le plus important est rebaptisé
par exemple le certaines bases est ce
que ça serait pas un signal fort
finalement comme le pensent les
démocrates pour calmer une situation
délicate
aujourd'hui aux états unis vous voyez
cda achats démarche s'il ya toujours un
mais un droit un bras ça s'arrête jamais
je crois que l'histoire il faut laisser
l'histoire est tel qu'il était
l'histoire fait ce qui est les etats
unis rod aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a
évolué et a du travail à faire il ya des
problèmes au sein de notre société
américaine on va avancer ensemble avec
intelligence de recul avec détermination
pour trouver des solutions pragmatiques
aux problèmes des toutes les minorités
aux états unis et à toutes les personnes
beaucoup ont dénoncé l'attitude de
donald trump ces derniers jours
notamment sur ses positions concernant
la question du racisme dans la police
est ce qu'il a été trop discret selon
vous je crois qu'il a pas voulu mettre
de l'huile sur le feu parce que comme
vous avez remarqué
chaque fois que monsieur 30 fait de
déclaration les déclarations sont
présentés de manière détournée par les
médias il a préféré rester silencieux et
laisser les choses se passent de cette
manière il a des
a dit il ya plusieurs jours qui la mort
de monsieur floyd était tragique était
la violence policière signant là doit
être puni au niveau individuel par les
éléments racistes qui existe tampa dans
toutes les sphères de notre pays
alors ce débat sur les violences
policières le racisme systémique le
passé esclavagiste des états unis est-ce
qu'il peut compromettre les chances de
réélection de donald trump ou l inverse
pourquoi pas remobiliser sa base je
pense c'est une démarche très grave de
la part des démocrates d'accuser
monsieur trompe et l'amérique du racisme
systémique
je pense que c'est une honte pour tous
les américains qui font tous les jours
ah qu'ils essaient de promouvoir
l'égalité un seul de leurs familles dans
au sein de leur entreprise au sein de
l'école ai dit ok il ya un racing
systémique
c'est vraiment une honte je pense qu'on
peut pas généraliser et je pense que
c'est ça demande plus de respect pour
tous les autres américains et j'ai pensé
généralisée de cette manière là c'est
aussi des critiques et l'ensemble des
mairies qu'un qui ne sont pas des
racistes
merci beaucoup randria lowe's d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat franco américain et
président de république en over 6 france